you
you
I'm going to talk to you a little bit
about ethics around making software and
not only do I not have any slides
there's also no code and it's not about
JavaScript so I'm afraid I'm gonna have
to I'm gonna have to disappoint you a
little bit and when I was practicing
this this took me between 20 and 40
minutes so literally anything can happen
but I think it's really important to
talk about an ethics of our work and and
it's not something that gets talked
about a lot and I think the reason for
it is that a lot of people especially
who don't necessarily have a technical
background tend to think that well you
know computing is this kind of objective
for most scientific thing and therefore
by extension these qualities apply also
to all technologies that are being made
and what's even worse I think is that
this kind of thinking applies also to
people who make technology so they
assumed often to be more logical more
free from human bias and somehow
magically not very human not susceptible
to emotions which is you know [ __ ]
and so we tell you about some projects
that I think really get my point across
that technologies and body and
communicate the ideas of people who made
them and why I think in sponsor to think
about these things consciously when you
make technology and because these things
really matter so in 2010 while I was
still studying at university I want to
speak to Margot Boden who is a
researcher in the fields of cognitive
and computer science psychology
artificial intelligence and I went to
speak to her about self ethics of
developing human-like robot companions
mainly for applications in serve
providing medical care or education and
so on and as we were talking about it
she told me a story of San George's
Hospital st. George's Medical Hospital
College in London which is a medical
school and which is very popular because
it's a very good school and therefore
every year they get quite a lot of
applicants so the applicants go through
kind of multistage
education process offense they're kind
of like rated on this of grades and like
the classes they took and things like
that and on the basis of diamond people
decide whether it's worth to invite such
a potential students to an interview and
then like once they invited to interview
there's like some other stuff that
happens that I'm not really sure about
but I'm so they've decided that this
first part of a process could be easily
automated and it's the part of a process
that's really labor-intensive and it
takes a lot of staff time to kind of go
for all the applications and decide who
is worthy of interviewing so in 1980s
and San George's Medical Hospital
decided to develop a computer program
that could deal with their initial stage
of the application the application
process and so they've devised a certain
rules that were given statistical
statistical waiting and these rules were
to do with like what what grades they
got for which subject and so on and then
the students were so marked an order of
preference depend on how many points
they scored and then like there was a
threshold establish above which they
would get invited to an interview so
what happens that once they developed a
system they started to tweak the
statistical weightings and applying to
all the different options and based on
previous year's data set like on who
applied and what kind of grades they had
and so on and who ended up getting
invited then they tweaked the program to
basically exactly replicate the results
they got in the previous yes so then
between 1982 and 1996 they use the
program to help them in that with the
admission system and that carried on
only answer 1996 when two members of
staff have complained to commission of
racial equality that the admission
system essentially was discriminating
against people of color and also that
was given not enough prominence to women
and people from poorer backgrounds now
the software itself
was only performing very simple
calculations very simple computations
that you know and also as a not a human
agent software itself doesn't have any
prejudices and biases but because it was
made by people who had themselves and
examined prejudices they ended up
creating it so that the software
replicated in a seemingly objective
manner now it would be very unfair of me
to suggest that this was done
deliberately because at the time some
george's medical school was the most
diverse college in entire England and
and therefore I think what happened
there is that people who didn't
necessarily think about their own biases
ended up replicating them um I think
it's also really interesting that in
this case this was only uncovered after
a self human was removed from the
process so once software took over it
was okay for people to complain about
its biases and bring them to light but
when it was your colleagues doing it
perhaps it was a little bit more
difficult so I think some projects end
up some expressing values of people even
though people didn't necessarily build
them into the projects for example and
Google glass is the kind of technology
where a lot of people bring to light the
fact that they're kind of scared of the
privacy implications of technology like
that being widespread and potentially
always connected and always recording
and they worry about who is an ownership
of the data that is being captured who
stores it who has access to it and where
they as a person featuring in this data
you have any kind of access to it or
whether you even know that this data
exists and but I think it's really
important to think that the team that
has designed it although I don't
actually know because I was in the part
of it and i don't really know anybody at
Google but I assume that when it comes
to designing products like that first
things that come to mind is you
exploring the impossible the desire to
create something that hasn't been
created before the desire to bring
computing to pass that normally would
require you to switch off and do
something else and focus on a device so
instead you kind of like start
seamlessly integrated into your life and
the privacy implications don't necessary
feature on the list of priorities of a
team that designs a product like that
and it's not necessarily a bad thing and
I think it's just a fact that exists
that you have company cultures that have
certain sets of priorities and you have
people working in teams that have
certain sets of priorities and these
things end up being embedded in the
product that these teams create so
sometimes I disagree with the priorities
of people who make stuff and these
things make me very angry and I
sometimes wonder whether the decisions
they make are by design everything
whether they are aware of the
implications of the things they do so
for example sorry for example there is a
new wave of businesses like TaskRabbit
or crowdsource or crowd flower which
basically operates on the idea that as a
business you often have a lot of tasks
that are fairly small or repetitive or
sometimes they're kind of unique and
they're not going to repeat so instead
of like employing people to perform
certain tasks it would be better if you
could just like get the stuff done and
then get on with your work so these
businesses essentially allow you to
Commission specific tasks to be
completed and you only pay sir fat ass
or pair time that it takes to complete
it and in a way like this enables
certain businesses to exist or to get
the work done so it
you know provides a booming economy for
certain types of businesses but it also
means that you're completely bypassing
employment laws so you don't have to
care about your workers health you don't
have to care whether they're insured or
whether they have any pension provision
you don't have to care whether they have
a healthy workplace to be working from
oh where did they get to do and whether
they get to take breaks or eat
sufficient amounts of food and so on all
you care about is the low price so by
building technologies that enable this
kind of exchange and you are essentially
potentially changing the the sort of way
of work of working for people in the
future um you know workers rights and
something that is just like an add-on
that you can conveniently remove when it
suits you there's something that we have
fought for for many years to establish
to make sure that there is actually a
healthy a healthy and productive work
for us so in cases of businesses like
that I sometimes wonder you know did
people not think about the repercussions
of creating these businesses but on the
other hand they also mean that other
types of businesses can get stuff done
and therefore they can exist so it's
like a double-edged sword and but there
are projects that and very clearly and
very deliberately and so communicate the
values of people who have created them
and who work for them one such example
that I think is my favorite is Wikipedia
no Wikipedia when it was created and
very deliberately it was created based
on a set of principles and these
principles permeate everything that is
to do with the project from software to
sort of community guidelines so um there
are a few principles that Wikipedia was
built upon and indifference of language
communities they're slightly vary in the
kind of written down site differently
and
the not um not very definitive but the
kind of like very general ideas and
English language one english-language
wikipedia defines them as five pillars
and these are openness of the community
kindness and respect towards other
people and assertion of freedoms and in
a little bit more detail they speak
about in like so first of all they
define that Wikipedia is an encyclopedia
and therefore it's not an advertising
platform it's not a directory of
information and and it's not a
collection of just random information
there has to be a purpose to everything
they do and and this kind of idea helps
wikipedia maintain a good quality of
content another idea is that it's
written from neutral point of view so
your personal opinion is not welcome
you're supposed to characterize facts
rather than interpret them and together
with the surprise principal and these
two things mean that quality of content
on Wikipedia is generally held up to
very high standards then there's a
freedom principle which means that not
only is the content free to access you
are also free to contribute so you can
freely modify it you can adopt it and
you can share it he can edit it and you
can use it for any purpose you like and
this is like my favorite principle
because essentially and it creates a
sort of shine that totally transcends
all human differences so no matter where
you from no matter what is your
background and you can contribute to
this amazing project and the only thing
that matters is that you want to do
something and you want to help out and
like one of the key sort of features of
Wikipedia that stems from this principle
is that to ensure that there are no
barriers to entry like you can edit
anonymously you can register and
a nickname or you can register under
your full name but to remove all the
barriers like you don't have to register
at all so you just like you can edit it
anonymously which is really important
and penultimate pillar on which
Wikipedia is built is following the
Wikipedia etiquette which is that
personal attacks are not welcome this is
not the place to be arguing about stuff
this is not a place for personal attacks
this is the place we report like the
highest of social standards so that we
can collaborate on something that's
really important and this is also
important to the previous principle the
principle of freedom because if you have
a situation where you have to fight
people on a personal level to contribute
to the project that means you can't
contribute to the project so this is
removing and another barrier to entry
and the last one is that there are no
firm rules and therefore you can't make
your own decisions and you can take
responsibility for the things you do in
Wikipedia and if they are wrong then
community will work it out and tell you
but essentially you're given the freedom
to kind of owned part of the project and
make almost executive decisions so from
the very beginning the set of values for
shapes like the feature set of the
software that exists but not only it
also shapes how the community guidelines
are constructed and how the community
around wikipedias run and it's a success
story in many ways it's the largest
reference like one of the largest
reference websites and and the amount of
contribution it receives is absolutely
enormous and it's it's a limit the
contributions are on a very broad range
of subjects as well unlike printed
encyclopedias and the longer the
articles exist and the longer they're
being talked about and they're more
consensus is achieved on a lot of issues
and the more people contribute so you
end up with articles that are very
comprehensive and usually very factually
accurate so these ideals of like freedom
and openness are the ones that I
personally very very deeply and this
amazing idea that you know you can
contribute whoever you are and your
contributions only matter based on their
own merit is super powerful but when
people talk about meritocracy and they
imagine that simply by virtue of
removing barriers to entry and allowing
everybody to contribute in a in a good
environment then the contributions will
accurately reflect society and will
provide equal opportunities to
contribute but despite being called the
sum of all human knowledge Wikipedia is
only the sum of knowledge of people who
are already online and who have time and
ability to contribute despite the best
intentions only nine percent of
contributors identify as female and and
Wikipedia recognizes that this is
something that needs a lot of work now
what's really cool about it is that they
recognize that the problem is no longer
technical because the barriers have been
removed but they recognize this is a
social program and therefore they've
devised social ways of dealing with it
so for example and they appoint and
university ambassadors who sort of
evangelize about Wikipedia and try to
broaden their kind of like Britain the I
try to get contributions from serve
broader demographic done already exist
and and but even that doesn't address
the fact that only a third of the global
population is online so despite various
attempts until we fix infrastructure and
we can't imagine that there's going to
be an equality of participation
opportunity now I've been trained as a
designer I started design on university
not computer science and as a designer
you kind of learn to think that when
you're assessing whether a project is
successful
you have to remember that every single
design and is always being used in a
specific context so you have your object
whatever it might be and and it's used
in a specific physical place by a
specific person and the person and
displays are always under various
influences beat political financial
cultural environmental technical and
these may or may not differ from the
context under which you are creating
this stuff and the design that doesn't
take these contacts into account and
doesn't respond to them is essentially a
failed design because nothing can exist
in the vacuum expecting something to
exist in a perfect world is essentially
just rejecting reality so I've been
thinking about this in relation to
Wikipedia and I wonder whether the lofty
ideals baked right into it and somehow
make for a failed design because it
fails to sort of respond to a world in
which not everybody can actually
contribute and freedom to share
information isn't just dictated by you
know your ability to make it so that
everybody can edit it but also by
circumstances beyond potential
contributors control but technology is a
cultural product and as such not only
does it reflect the culture that was
created in but actually actively shapes
the culture of the future so not only
does it embody values of the people who
made it but also somehow expresses the
virus back into the world and kind of
creates the world in which these values
become pervasive so it can be a
transformative tool because it
communicates something about what we
want the world to be cliff who proposed
developing software engineer a code of
ethics said this software is a form of
expression and can contain both
entertainment and commentary on society
politics and economics so to me the more
I think about it the more Wikipedia
seems this kind of a expect expressive
speculative project a communicates the
idea that we want to live in a world
where everybody can contribute and we
all see value in
doing something together and doing
something of great importance that we
can then all share and use but there are
many projects that don't necessarily
receive this kind of careful
consideration when they're being created
like Wikipedia did so when I spoke to my
great bowden I asked what she thought
about why that was and she said that you
know many people making software I still
very young so they don't really think
about consequences of their own actions
and perhaps you know they haven't yet
experienced a lot of the world so maybe
they haven't made me exposed to
diversity or old age and you know they
haven't they have no way of kind of
relating to their own life and with
these things because they just haven't
had the chance to like experience so
much of the world yet and also you know
they're dealing with machines so they
often kind of excused for antisocial
behavior and not being interested in
other people because they would rather
sit and program all day also another
interesting thing she said was that
instead of being excited about the
culture and social problems we face the
actual real problems in the world that
we could be solving people often just
get excited about the technical
challenges as if they're kind of
replacement for dealing with the actual
problems that we should be solving as a
society now designers and civil
engineers get taught ethics and to
prepare them for real life work
experience and they get taught at
University but despite the incredible
power of software engineering and how it
affects the world and how it shapes it
like that isn't necessarily the case
also if it were the case like a lot of
us are entirely self-taught so that
wouldn't necessarily make a big
difference so I would like you to think
about like everyday decisions you make
when you're creating stuff you know and
like some of these decisions might be
absolutely huge and painful and legally
risky like ladar Levison who was built
in love a bit and hosting him for 10
years
email system that Edwards Norman Snowden
reportedly used and when faced with the
potential of having to reveal some of
his customers data to national security
agency decided to shut down the whole
system now most of us are interfaced
with ethical challenges of that
magnitude but even like small things we
deal with every day can have like a
massive impact on people's lives for
example you know every day I make
decisions about like what kind of data
do we collect about our customers well
how is it story who has access to you
know do we collect more than necessary
who do we share it with and so on but it
isn't just about storage and collection
of data and for example of my work we
built a lot of different digital
products and in every single one of them
we've got a people tie table in the
database instead of very usual users
table because we thought that it would
make us talk about people differently
and and it did it's slightly less
dehumanizing to think of people as
individuals than it is about a group of
users so I think my last point is that
technology is made by people and it's
used by people and therefore it's a
social and cultural thing you can
somehow remove magically people from the
equation so you can't get technology
that's somehow objective and doesn't
express human values and you can't
design it and make it in a vacuum where
you don't understand how people use it
and what they want from it and you are
building tools of the future you are
building the things that are shaping how
we are going to be thinking about the
world in years to come and the things
that you make might enable people to for
example communicate or to express
themselves to do all the things they
might need to get on with their lives
technology now mediates pretty much
every sphere of our lives it's in the
banking system it's in a healthcare
provision and enables law enforcement
and justice system and it mediates our
personal communications will be it
personal or
professional or intimate and it's a part
of our culture and it helps us create us
so essentially technology is like one of
those things that lets people and lack
the human rights and if it sounds like
it's a massive responsibility that's
because it is so I would like you to
basically take that responsibility and
like our political leanings may vary and
we might disagree with me on a lot of
points but I think I would be successful
if you just think about it and know what
it is that you want the world to be and
you are prepared to stand take a stand
and make decisions that you could be
proud of because making the world a
better place it is your job thank you
you